no no things are having calmed at all
I'd say last night there have been what
about 150 arrests up and down France
including plenty here in nontera this is
the district where the 17 year old Niall
was shot by a police officer as as we've
been hearing that officer is now being
placed under formal investigation
at the prosecutor has started laying out
their case which it says the car that
and I was driving jumped a red light was
stopped by police officers and that he
was then shot as he went to uh to drive
off and they said that that was at 8 19
in the morning when he crashed and that
he was formally declared dead just over
or just under an hour later now that has
led to these violent confrontations uh
there's some evidence of it I have to
say if you look uh let me just show you
down here on the the road you can see
these Scorch marks all over the tarmac
you get this all-round non-term these
are areas where during the night
basically fiery barricades are created
whereas uh inflammable liquid or bins
are put in the road set on fire in order
to disrupt police getting around this
area that happened last night and also
just up the road there
absolutely next to where we are staying
here in Montana uh a Depot for an
electricity company was set on fire and
as we watched in the small hours between
two and four a.m a whole series of their
Vans
um I think eight or nine of them were
set on fire and exploded right next uh
to us a conflagration fire brigade
eventually put that up but this sort of
stuff is happening around uh France it's
not just nontera it's also amio and Lil
and Leo and Toulouse and other places
and of course multiple suburbs of Paris
and this isn't just about the death of
this 17 year old that is the Catalyst
for it but it is also about huge
discontent in places like this mistrust
of the police sense of economic social
cultural isolation literacy levels here
are much lower than the rest of France
so is employment levels there is a
disconnect clearly between a place like
non-terre and the French government that
puts macaron in that difficult position
calling for calm but also aware that he
has to be seen to be doing something
while also sticking up for the police
and is it going to calm down I don't
necessarily think so today there is a
March or at least a protest an event
happening at the perfect church that
affected the Town Hall in Monte just
near where where we are at the moment
and that is important because not only
is that a heartbeat of the community
it's just over the Square from where
this uh this car now crashed his car and
died so that will be a huge focal point
for for non-terre and I suspect a lot of
the country will be watching that as
well and the question will be as
Darkness Falls what happens here what
happens in the rest of France is this
going to start to diminish or will it
grow and I think the lesson we've
learned from all these fires is that it
takes a small spark to start them it's
very hard to put them out whether that
is a real fire or whether this is this
inflammatory political position that is
being used by people to start these
conflicts here and across France